غضب الان الى تطورات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه حيث تعرضت مدينه دميتك
والاحياء المجاوره لها لقصف عنيف من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه وخلف القصف الاوكراني
على دنيا 17 اصابه وقتلين من جانبها رده
روسيا على قصف مركزي تجنيد الروسيين في
دنياك بعده ضربات اهمها قصف قاعده تجنيد
عسكريه يتواجد بها قرابه 200 جندي اوكراني
في منطقه
من جهتها اعلنت هيئه الاركاني في الجيش
الاوكراني تنفيذها 13 هجوم صاروخيا
ومدفعيا على مواقع على القوات الروسيه
خلال 24
جيش الاوكراني وفي بيانه الى احباط
محاولات الروسيه في 15 منطقه
جيش الاوكراني روسيا بقص في مناطق ماهوله
في الضفه اليمنى من نهر دروبسون تهديد
اضطرابات الجويه
في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا لا يزال مستمر
كما اعلنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
الجيش الاوكراني اسقط نحو 500 طائره من
دون طيار ايرانيه الصنع منذ سبتمبر
الماضيه واكد المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان قوات الدفاع الجوي دمرت
جميع الطائرات المسيره التي اطلقتها روسيا
في هجومها المكثفه في خلال عطله راس السنه
البالغ عددها 84 طائره
من جهتها اعلنت هيئه او اكد الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان هناك خططه روسيه لحمله
طويله من هجمات الطائرات من دون طيار
هدفها يضعف الروح المعنويه مشيرا الى انه
تلقى تقارير استخباراتيه تشير الى ان
موسكو ستشن الهجمات باستخدام طائرات شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع
مين معي
باستخدام طائرات شاهد المسيره ومن المحتمل
ان يكون الهدف من وراء ذلك استنزاف شعبنا
وانظمه الدفاع عن الجويه وقطاع الطاقه
لدينا نحن نتصرف ونفعل كل ما بوسعنا
لافشالهم من تحقيق اهدافهم
اثارت الغارات الجويه الاوكرانيه الاخيره
على معسكر نتابع للقوات الروسيه رداتها
فعلا وانتقادات داخل روسيا حيث طلب قوميون
ومشرعون بمعاقبه قاده عسكريين اتهموهم
بتجاهل المخاطر التي تسببت بمقتل 63 جنديا
من القوات الروسيه في مكيفا بدنيتك ويبن
المنتقدون مطالباتهم هذه على ان الجنود
كانوا يقيمون قرب مستودعا للذخيره في
الموقع الذي اصيب بصواريخ هيمارس امريكيه
الصنع فيما ذكر مدونون عسكريون الروس ان
القاده كانوا على علم بان المبنى الذي
تعرض للقصف في مكه
كبير بسبب تخزين الذخيره يقع في مرمى
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه من جانبه طلب
الرئيس السابق لمجلس الاتحاد طلب مسائله
جنائيه للمسؤولين الذين سمحوا بتكديس جنود
في مبنى دون توفير حمايه لهم
نتابع مع مراسيلينا من موسكو ومنكياف عبد
الجواد الرشد وحذيفه عادل مرحبا بكما عبد
الجواد ابدا معك هل سيكون هناك محاسبه
وعقاب كما يطالب القوميون للقاده
العسكريين بعد استهداف الجنود الروسي في
مكيفا
مساء الخير صهيب لك ولي حذيفه حتى هذه
اللحظه رسميا لا يتم الحديث رغم كل
الانتقادات الكبيره من اطراف عده بما يخص
ما حدث في دينيس ليله طبعا راس السنه
وسقوط 10 القتلى والجرحى بضرباته اوكرانيه
طبعا العديد من الاصوات في البلاد خرجت
وتحدثت عن سوء التنظيم وسير العمليه
العسكريه والجميع اصبح يعود للوراء قليلا
ويتذكر وينشر كلمات الرئيس شيشاني رمضان
قديره الذي انتقد سير العمليه مرات عده في
السابقه لكن طبعا اليوم الجميع اصبح يتحدث
وينظر بعين الواقع الى ما حدث هناك بانه
امر الصعب طبعا وسقوط هذا العدد الكبير
خاصه ان الجنود الذين سقطوا هم من من يعني
من تلك الفئه التي تم تعبئهم خلال الفتره
الماضيه وكانوا قذفهم يقومون بارسال رسائل
نصيه ورسائل عبله عبر وسائط اخرى الى
ذويهم يهنونهم باعياد طبعا راس الميلاد
راس السنه والميلاد لكن الوضع حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يخرج اي شيء رسمي ينبئ او يتحدث
عن معاقبه احد باعتبار ان العمليه
العسكريه اليوم فيدخل في اصعب يعني هو
واقفها نلاحظ بان موسكو بدات بالرد بشكل
جدي كبير على ما حدث ليله راس السنه
الاعداد
الاوكرانيين تمكنوا من تحديد المواقعهم
بعد ما فتحوا جوالاتهم همم وقاموا
باستهدافهم بصواريخ حذيفه في كيف اسالك
هنا عن الترقب الاوكراني للرد الذي بدا
بالفعل كما قال همم عبد الجواد ولكن كيف
تتحضر اوكرانيا لمختلف السيناريوهات بعد
هذه الضربه الموجعه التي اعترف بها روسيا
نعم تحياتي صهيب لك ولزامير عبد الجواد
طبعا ااه باشا الاتحاد الروسي بتنفيذ
ضربات استمرت لثلاثه ايام هذه الغارات
الجويه استهدفت العاصمه كيف ومعظم المدن
الاوكرانيه بمسيرات عديده ولكن الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني استطاع ان يسقط جميع هذه
المسايرات ولم ينفذ صاروخ واحد الى الى
يعني الوجه التي وجهها ولا طائره مسيره
كان هنالك اصابات قليله جدا جراء شظايا
سقطت من احد من احد الصواريخ ومن ايضا
طائره مسيره ولكن هذه الضربه الاخيره
رهيبه اليوم كان هناك ضربات جديده لجيش
اوكراني كما سماها بيان ال- همم هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الاوكرانيه همم
يعني همم النصر جديد في شوكولاته ايضا
ضربه صاروخيه لمراكز التجمع القوات
الروسيه وقال البيان انه تم قتل
وما بين قتيل وجريحه 500 فرد من افراد
القوات المسلحه الروسيه كذلك ايضا اا في
منطقه الدونيسك تم تدمير 11 دبابه وتم
السيطره على الطريقه الاستراتيجي صفاته
كريم وهذا الطريق تقاتل القوات الاوكرانيه
من اجله منذ عده ايامه اليوم اعلن رسميا
للسيطر عليه وهذا طريق هام جدا الان
القوات التي تقدم في كريم هي عاجزه عن
الحصول على الامدادات تتخذ الطرق وعره جدا
حذيفه وعبد الجواد ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود
اليكما في زاويه اخرى
او لا سنكتب اذا معكم بهذا ال- القدر على
انه يتابع معكما همم في نشره لاحقا اذا
تطورات الوضع الميداني في اوكرانيا